when I mentoring young entrepreneurs I
ask them about money and their business
model when I get an answer like we'll
throw some ads here and there it's make
me real said it's the wrong answer you
must have a solid business model in
place that will put your company on the
profitable track so even if ads are the
answer to your monetization model you
need to put a little bit more thought
into it so let's define what an ad is
first basically it's any public
announcement of something that someone
wants to sell on the web we have ads in
the form of text image video or
interactive media the power of these ads
is coming from the fact that they are
targeted to site content and art
audience you make ad spaces also known
as ad inventory available on your site
advertisers bid to show their ads on
your site and the highest bid wins then
you get paid when users click on the ads
this model works when you have lucrative
traffic meaning you focus on verticals
that advertisers are interesting in for
example a finance or an automotive site
with a lot of users will earn higher CPM
s then a site that focus on fish or
white elephants